what's the fastest way to learn
screenwriting the fastest way of
learning screenwriting is very easy read
scripts that simple
so people who write novels very often
just sit down in their computer and they
start writing but chances are they've
read lots of novels in their lives
almost certainly so there's this famous
saying you know if you want to know how
to write you just read read read and
write write write
so script writing is exactly the same
read lots of scripts what I find really
strange is participants of my workshops
and people who come to my talks and
stuff I'm like how many of you have read
a feature film script and like out of
the 40 people maybe it's a second thing
but not many people have read the
features on TripIt they want to write
movies because they've watched lots of
movies so they think because they're a
movie fan and they like to watch movies
that they can write scripts and I'm like
but you've never seen this document of a
script properly you may have read you
know transcriptions of script but you
never looked at the formatting and the
layout and the style and the structure
and all this kind of thing so I would
say just read as many scripts as you can
and they're all available online you
know there are websites where you can
get them and just because I mean I think
that's how we learn it's just from
reading and I mean if you read many many
feature film scripts then you'll end up
writing features oh that's the for me
that's the fast track to writing good
scripts is reading lots of scripts and
they're there it's available you can
read the screen writing books on how to
write scripts but really if you just
read the scripts lots of them and keep
up to date with what's happening in the
trends of the writing styles and how
things are changing through the years so
you know don't just read Casablanca and
Chinatown because there are certain
formatting at a certain time read
current scripts as well interested in TV
series read TV series scripts because
they're also written in a different
style and then you start to see the
writers voice and then perhaps from that
you can start writing your own voice so
I would say the fast track is just read
loads of scripts then of course write
the scripts so my first trip that I ever
wrote does not exist anymore
anyway in this world I hope there's no
digital copy of it it was terrible
it probably had a lot of formatting
errors it was it was just you know
wasn't terrible it was just misguided
youth enthusiasm of youth so you've got
to write quite a lot to get that's the
Vario system at
you know you get the genius writer you
may write a first script and it's like
fantastic but I'd say write a few times
and see how it works get feedback as
well from people who are not your mother
or your best friend and and then rewrite
that script and then you'll start to get
somewhere yeah it's I suppose that's the
fast-track to you to writing it goes
without saying that one needs to watch
lots of movies for television and BC you
know steeped in that world yeah
and then to make it really good I was
gonna say read the book three wells of
screenwriting but well that's your book
yeah yeah but what I want to say is tap
into what only you can bring into the
script so it's all very well reading
loads of scripts and writing those the
scripts if you just going to write
another crime thriller or you know
something that someone else can do
better
what can you write what's the only in
the story that only you can roll the
stories and you can write themes that
only you can write if you can tap into
that then you are really putting
something in there that is authentic and
it'll recognize it when they read it
immediately so I added a lot of script
reading in the past and for competitions
and I've read too many scripts I'm yeah
for my own sanity but when you're
reading them you you suddenly something
just leaps off the page and that's an
authenticity it's a moment of of
realness a real character moment a real
moment of subtlety a real location a
real something that just leaps off the
page if you can put that in your scripts
and I really believe that you'll have an
advantage over of at the script so yeah
read lots of scripts and write the kind
of scripts and you can write and what
was the first script that you read oh
that's another great question hmm
do you remember the year it was probably
quite late I was a while at RIT place
are you the first things I read will
play a stage plays before I read scripts
things like waiting for God and these
like plays that are you know the
standard plays you really if you're
doing an English degree or something it
in South Africa we've read some plays
and the first script I read was probably
cinema paradiso and if you know that
it's a it's a movie but an Italian
filmmaker Giuseppe Tornatore anyone he
did one the many many years ago it's
beautiful movie cinema paradiso and shot
it and it's great and I love that movie
and I think that was the first script I
ever bought and the first script I ever
read but just the KVA goes it was one of
those transcripted scripts that you can
buy so it's like a book version of a
script and it's you know it's got all
the dialogue and sat on it and some of
the action but it wasn't formatted in a
correct script format I think the first
one I probably read was Chinatown in
proper script formatting but I remember
buying the book of cinema paradiso and
reading it and being able to picture all
the scenes in my head and that's a
that's a real skill that people kind of
have to develop you know you got to buy
the you've got to read these scripts to
picture it in your head to feel what it
feels like so that when you write it you
can make someone picture those scenes in
their head it's a it's a different thing
I often say that for me when people
think they can write scripts without
reading scripts it's like going to a
classical concert and listening to a
piece of classical music and thinking oh
I love this music I'm gonna go home and
write some music now and just writing
music randomly with dots and squiggles
because you know there's dots and
squiggles and lines and just kind of
writing some sort of a document that's
you think looks like sheet music and
then handing it over to someone and
expecting them to play they're not gonna
understand and it's like a architect
going you know if you see a beautiful
building and you think oh this buildings
really beautiful I love this building
and I like buildings and I understand
buildings and I like Art Deco style I'm
gonna go home and design a building and
you just kind of design the building
without having looked at blueprints or
read sheet music that's why you've gotta
read scripts and movie is not a script
it's a it's a different thing they serve
different kind of functions almost so
yeah so so you can't be Frank Gehry
unless you yeah exactly right yeah yeah
right right and the same thing you can't
be William Goldman yeah whatever you
wanted Radian although I do think that
yeah it's all about being able to evoke
an emotion in the reader so maybe they
could they can do that they already had
a way of doing it somehow in their
writing you know so that's yeah I know
I think people think of the notion of
genius or savant or something and they
think well maybe I can duplicate the
same without having to take all the
steps yeah in between yeah and and I
think you know we hear these stories of
people just from from you know h.5 yes I
will do something amazing and maybe it
is inside of us but it needs a little
coaching or yeah I think screenwriting
though is a bit of a Croft so you don't
actually hear of savants peen writers
like I've never heard of a five-year-old
writing a great script or you know
17-year old running a great script
sometimes you can get you know the woman
who wrote you know I forget she was
quite a blow because she was relatively
young when she wrote that but we don't
know the back I don't really know
actually what happened there I know some
of the story but it we just because it's
a craft it it's like like pottery or
something you know you you don't just if
you're a genius Potter you still have to
practice to get the pot to be correct
and I really believe with screenwriting
it is a bit of a craft and so we don't
get these savants we just don't we don't
get the great seventeen-year-old gonna
fetch the best screen running Ward not
yet although it might change because the
youngsters nowadays and access they have
to filmmaking ability is very exciting
and amazing I mean they've got thing
phones you know stuff on the apps they
can just make music videos just like
that so maybe it'll change maybe in the
future the ability to make what's in
your head won't have this craft in
between step and maybe you will have
youngsters making the best films ever
you know we'd be nice
you